- What's up 2017?
We're going to try..
- Hey internet, it's you favorite duo.
- Kate and Jared, Jared and Kate.
- Kate and Jared back at it.
- We're going to try out
some fast foods of 2017.
(upbeat music)
- Cool. Let's do it.
Alright, so yeah, we're going to try out
some items that came out in 2017.
I'm a little skeptical about these
newfangled fast foods.
I'm more like a classic fast food guy.
Taco Bell, we're here at Taco Bell.
Do you have the blue raspberry freeze?
- It's frosty.
- Thank you.
- [Taco Bell Worker] Have a good day.
- [Kate] Thank you.
- [Jared] Alright.
- Cheers.
- Blue raspberry freeze.
- This is good, this is good.
- You know there aren't
any blue raspberries?
- That makes sense.
- Oh I got a brain freeze.
Why are they getting worse?
- Brain freezes are crazy.
- (imitating Kate)
Brain freezes are crazy.
It works.
This would complement a taco supreme well.
- Oh yeah.
- Five out of ten. I might get it.
- I would do a four out of ten.
But if it was that particular
day in the summertime,
and I'm shredding with my friends.
I might be tired to get this.
- We're gonna try the
Ribeye Havarti Burger.
- Havarti Burger.
- From Jack in the Box,
which we're only gonna get one,
I didn't bring any like knife or scissors.
- I think we're gonna ask them to cut it.
- I think that's a bad idea.
Is there any way you can cut that in half?
- [Jack In The Box Worker] Sure.
- Thank you.
And, do you have a jumpin' jack splash?
It's very moist looking.
- Red wine glazed, cheers.
- Cheers.
- You know what, I'm getting
this at a restaurant.
A burger that, it feels
like you're drinking it.
- Wanna try some of this
jumpin' jack splash?
- You know I do.
- [Jared] So if this is about,
this is just like Hawaiian punch.
- Ooh.
- It tastes like the,
like those barrel drinks.
Pretty good.
- Seven out of ten.
(laughter)
♪We're trying out foods♪
- ♪Fast foods♪
- ♪Fast foods from 2017♪
- Alright, off to Burger King
for some milkshakes to
wash down that burger.
- ♪Burger King for milkshakes♪
- A Cinnamon Toast Crunch milkshake
and a flamin' hot mac and cheetos.
Alright, thank you.
This looks crazy.
It looks like an alien.
- [Kate] Great.
- [Jared] Alright.
- One, two, three.
- Oh.
It's really dry.
- It's so dry.
I'm sure these were good yesterday.
- Maybe in the lab,
they had a good version.
But somewhere into mass production,
it went bad.
- I don't know where
the melt-y cheese was.
- There's hope in,
there's a Cinnamon Toast Crunch milkshake,
what do you want?
- [Kate] I'll try the Lucky Charms.
I'm already holding it.
- [Jared] Whoa.
- Wow! It really does
taste like Lucky Charms.
- It's a good breakfast replacement.
- Dang.
- Alright, you did alright with
the milkshakes, Burger King.
Milkshakes. Eight out of ten.
- The shakes were good.
- Shakes were pretty dope.
- Shakes were great.
Those Cheetos, give it zero out of ten.
♪And we're going to McDonald's♪
(vocalizing)
- ♪McDonald's♪
(laughter)
- [McDonald's Worker] Thank
you for choosing McDonald's,
may I take your order?
- [Jared] Yeah, do you
still have the Grand Mac?
- [McDonald's Worker] Not anymore.
- No!
- Do you have any new items?
They don't have the Grand Mac anymore.
2017 sucks.
So we're gonna make our own Grand Mac.
Out of two Big Macs.
It's a Grand Mac.
I love Big Macs.
I was really excited about the Grand Mac.
Oh, man. That is so good.
- Damn.
- Still alive.
- Alright, no Grand Mac.
But we did it. We tried.
- We tried.
- Next time, the lesson is
that you just gotta go for it
when you see it.
When it's there, do it now.
Live your life.
Cut to a slow motion of me
eating that Big Mac.
- But all in all, the stuff we did
have was pretty good.
- Yeah.
♪2017♪
- [Both] ♪2017♪
♪No more double chalupa♪
(vocalizing)
♪No more something♪
- ♪Everybody gonna poop, poop, poop♪
(squeaking)